Dove siete andati a cena Mmm mmm sì sì
carino ci sono stata un paio di volte Se
però vuoi mangiare davvero bene Mi devi
andare all'Acqua e sale un altro pianeta
ti costa di più ovviamente però la
qualità si paga eh in Spagna bello
Guarda Peccato che è già prenotato
perché se non avessi detto prima Ti
avrei consigliato la crociera nei fiordi
Sì guarda ma te lo dico perché io ho
visitato tutto il mondo più e più volte
e la crociera nei fiordi in particolare
la Norvegia e paesi nordici cioè proprio
un altro livello Sì perché Spagna -
Italia Comunque sono sempre il paese
Mediterraneo invece i paesi nordici
hanno tutto un altro fascino Però vabbè
ormai è già prenotato Beh ovviamente è
un mio consiglio Eh i soldi sono tuoi
Fai quello che vuoi ti capisco
perfettamente guarda perché io fino a
qualche tempo fa soffrivo tantissimo di
dolori mestruale poi poi ho risolto sai
come Prendi nota
piperita bagni caldi e salmone Ammo
salmone scottato 2 minuti da un lato 2
minuti dall'altro Sì te ne fai 5-6 al
giorno ti passa tutto Fidati tu prova e
mi dirai Avevi ragione Come sempre
d'altronde ah